i want to make a toast
to my new career
on housewives of beverly hills
hey not so fast abby lee miller is
merely pitching herself to be the newest
cast member on the real housewives of
beverly hills i cannot take any chances
although i i feel like i'm a risk taper
taker all the time you know i'm always
out there trying to take a chance on
something leave it to abby to put
herself out there the dance moms star
shared a video on her youtube channel
addressing a rumor that she's joining
the 90210 housewives a really big juicy
rumor me
abby lee miller joins the cast
of housewives of beverly hills how about
that andy andy cohen
call me
you have my number while we wait to see
what andy has to say about it abby
decides to do what she's known for
pyramid rankings yes i'm naming names
yep she's categorizing the ladies by
using the same pyramid system she used
on dance moms and um trash is the cast
in the process now on the bottom of the
pyramid starting with dorit kimsley on
the bottom
is
dorito
there is nothing
nothing exciting about you
boring but
let's face it
you are nothing like an original
housewife
ouch with the shade
next on the bottom row are diana jenkins
and crystal minkoff dianna jenkins the
glory
is not in writing a book
but having
written a book
but your book
was not on the new york times bestseller
list
it was on the most wanted list
crystal last i heard you were dumped by
14 friends
and now you're being done by me and
rounding out the bottom kathy hilton and
erica jane who she has some choice words
for erica i feel for you i get it i know
all about the federal indictments
believe me i can sympathize with you but
you still have to be on the bottom i
mean come on
yeah abby's referring to when she was
indicted by a grand jury in 2015 for
bankruptcy fraud and served time in
federal prison i i know that's what i'm
thinking as abby inches her way up the
pyramid the critiques seemingly soften
and abby's got some compliments and i
can critique and pick out everything for
cherie zampino and lisa rinna abby's all
in
cherie
i think you're great
i think you need a permanent contract
you and me babe let's go
next on the pyramid
lisa renna
everybody loves a good villain
and lisa i wish i had your killer body
oh andrew killer husband and the top two
spots they're going to abby's favorites
garcelle garcelle you are a fantastic
mother
and i haven't come in contact with too
many of those and next on the pyramid
o.g
kyle richards kyle
second
is the first to lose
maybe i shouldn't have done that
you know i did see that halloween kills
movie it was a little scary
yeah might want to avoid any run-ins
with kyle but the queen of abby's
pyramid is none other than herself uh
are we surprised i was going to put
kim richards
but instead
i put me
the newest housewives of beverly hills
tasman
[Applause]
of course abby did clarify in the
description box that she's only poking
fun and loves all the housewives we'll
have to just wait and see if bravo ends
up giving her a call but someone who
seems to be in full support of abby
stepping into a new role is her former
dance student jojo siwa
jojo who's currently a judge on so you
think you can dance recently told et she
wanted abby to step in as matthew
morrison's replacement i wanted to
suggest to the producers so bad abby lee
but then i was like i don't think they
think it was a good
i was like it was like kind of a joke
but also like it would work out well
like she is a dance brilliant genius
that career shift seems to be more in
line with abby's dance background but
who knows maybe she's the extra spice
the housewives of beverly hills
franchise needs i always am very
judgmental that's what i do
[Music]